[Music]
in famous lovers news also famous so
famous submitted by Jam from CT hmm a
newly released letter from Tupac's to
Madonna explains how race issues were
the cause of the break-up what okay
Ibiza no real would be together you were
Madonna to her well this a written
letter yes so in Old English what's
[ __ ] calligraphy pen go later V - I
don't even know if anyone on your
calligraphy anymore the world is keeping
us apart no two bosses a poet
that's why said ma Biche come on now pay
attention
so Madonna two years ago did confirm
that she did deep to puck in early 1994
but she didn't mention how long they
were dating and so recently this love
this letter that was written by to pop
while he was in prison in New York start
fifth and now it's being first time now
training auctioned off ha [ __ ] that ma
[ __ ] so here's to [ __ ] Madonna back
in the day that's such an interesting is
it is old high twelve years old I got
the same jewelry on it everything jobs
so here's older than him really she's
always been a very uh cool and able to
run boy whatever you want on and so
these are the letters that are being
auctioned off oh you're going to college
ruled yeah and there is some parts that
were blurred out I don't know why but L
really was how am i eating a [ __ ] on
[ __ ] sorry to your life the glitter
akheon this is written January 15 1995
at court boys yeah yeah doing Tupac
voice you enter in oh you got to do it
I've waited long I waited a long time to
tell you please [ __ ] with me
I've waited a long time to finally write
this mainly because I wanted us I can't
read it's [ __ ] writing mainly because
I was struggling to find all the answers
so that I would leave any unanswered
questions uh ah first and foremost I
must apologize to you because like you
said I haven't been the kind of friend I
know I am capable of being itch can you
understand that
he wrote the you before the inner on the
right you mm-hmm
elevator yep can you understand it wait
he also wrote you as in why oh you too
he's confusing me all right for you to
be seen with a black man wouldn't in any
way jeopardize your career if anything
it would make you seem much more open
and exciting but for me at least in my
previous perception I felt due to my
image I would be letting down half of
the people who made me what I thought I
was I never meant to hurt you an
interview where you said I'm off to
rehabilitate all the rappers and
basketball players or something to that
effect those words cut me deep see how I
had never known you to be with any
rapids besides myself it was at this
moment out of her and natural instinct
to strike back and defend my heart and
ego that I said a lot of things I didn't
even know that any at it can you feel me
let's do but can't do it in a two part
ways yeah in the top I'm questioning
myself it was hard okay in the time
since in the time sis as you can see I
have grown both spiritually a mentally
in no longer matters how I pursued
please understand my precious please
understand my previous position for
purpose persisted mr. perfect bridge
apart ok the public is that of a young
man with a limited experience with the
extremely famous sex symbol upper ma
pressure once again
this time much stronger and focused if
you are still interested I would like to
further discuss this would you but some
of it couldn't wait I felt compelled to
tell you just in case anything happened
to me please be careful Madonna
everybody is not as honorable as they
seem though are those whose hearts bled
with evil and empty they would not
hesitate to do you harm
let my father let's be pooped today PS
if there's any information you can share
with me regarding Jack and crew please
do it could very well be another life or
death always Tupac why is the sounds go
and there's another added part I don't
know how you feel about visiting me but
if you could find it in your heart I
would love to speak face-to-face with
you it's funny but this experience has
taught me not to take time for granted
this will just broke up with her and
after to meet with them again basically
list he's bipolar
well he's always been my hahaha I don't
know this writing doesn't match this
writing does not match okay fine yeah
4:30 in the morning really that's why
his writing 430 or 930 look like a born
it doesn't connect at the top [ __ ] you
love Tupac bad but he raps he rapped
with so much conviction no baby believe
I don't have a dad growing up and I did
[ __ ] a walk to woke up in the morning my
daddy watching me my dad's like what are
you talking about that's right I forgot
I just feel the pain no man like
Brenda's got a baby
dang dude he made me feel like I was
pregnant like damn I know I was like
it's not easy being a poor black single
mother with a problem yo I know [ __ ]
good that sound confessed now was that
difference between East Coast and the
west coast East Coast mad lyrical
spherical vehicle yeah I know west coast
had that [ __ ] feeling it was basic
but it was poetry with could
[ __ ] well then you better West Teresa
yeah but he claimed he was West Coast oh
yeah he got that West Coast evil Wes
tearfully near is gonna be like yeah he
was born there but any were you from
it's for you yes mmm-hmm crazy yes right
I can't let our data for the [ __ ] all
right here [ __ ] so much of it
you gotta [ __ ] do this straight
that's a folder um this also some deal
with this I can't do I can't do it just
handle this one everybody took pictures
with the west side I can't do it this
hand though I punched him anything with
this hand every time I can do my left
hand have to like hit it against there's
something to kanji I can't the swap
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah Wow
Wow Brown so in that time to join sticks
I am gonna burn a boss coast ma I like
biggie still I was big coupon I just was
annoyed of [ __ ] pasto P Diddy
oh I never considered him part of that
Oh like what why why you [ __ ] set up
a Benjamins baby like why are you in
that position what the [ __ ] are you
doing just stay out big is the big is
the one you know he's cool hi - foz
would talk [ __ ] about uh wasn't it Shawn
yeah chomped off account
yeah you know you have so many names W
clone Sean Diddy Combs I love when he
was such data it's like screaming she
had different screen names of oh no
can't keep the same one over hub was so
poetic go where why is it just hurt to
see now that's a really good question I
was trying to find that out too
I walked I because it a movie oh yeah
for the movie well I do know from what
some reported is that this letter was
from a quote from a close contact of
Madonna's who worked with her for over
20 years I [ __ ] up so they stole it
from a god it sounds like backstabbing
[ __ ] [ __ ] are they saying that my
daughter never got that was a love
letter a private love letter why would
Madonna give that [ __ ] away that should
be a part of her scrapbook in the
college I mean especially
be her scrapbook in her closet tucked
away collecting done that's how you know
it's special exactly she didn't throw it
away baby two pucks off oh man my
ambitions as a writer
oh my bishop did the water the only one
I knew word for word
dear mama the only one I like to look
classic name is one of them not the
whole album
all eyes on me man go album I got label
up to say more to save a lot I don't
know I like so many there's so many
there's Superman they're spart to talk
about the illusion this juice Tupac like
old-school [ __ ] got and then all the
way to like after his death and then
that oh yeah yeah the album came out
what was it with the what it was like
remember Eminem was like that he had
produced it right no it was before that
look so it's like he died but this was
during high school it was released and
then I forgot what album it was but then
little homies was on it oh no no I I
think so but so they're they're all
older songs but then the beats are new
yeah yeah that's the one with like the
broken wing song and the dogmas and
songs don't mention that was the one to
Eminem I think no no yeah that that
that's it's the one after that oh if I
see the album cover oh no well as a mean
Brenda I don't know
oh I think it's better day and a day
better days remember that one better
than better days talk about the better
days he had such good emotional music it
was good [ __ ] you music there was just
it depends on your dish it's like wine
do you don't know what you want yet
because on your move man when I die I
want [ __ ] that one song how many
brothers fell victim to the streets
where's the piece yellow Edward is a
heaven Laura jeans being laughs if I
told you that I never told this MA the
landlord left life goes off there's a
bill through the EPI hold breath
speaking in Madras bring rain break
quiet job incoming call
that's my [ __ ]
to play what outside oh you know what I
right now what's up ultimate daddy
you know what says you know what's the
ultimate cruising song and your [ __ ]
bucket but like you're like the [ __ ]
picture me rollin Oh we pulled it in my
bomb under big picture bebraud it only
know how there aren't too many peppers
they can enjoy the car this way I know
so people can drive that way glad that's
what it just felt good dog looks like a
core workout you can't think of it two
exercises without the spirit of life oh
yes it's like you're you're you you're
too poor to have a lowrider
exactly that's why you just get a Honda
Civic like this I kid when you drive
your car you got to make sure people
know the wound upon driving yeah yeah
you know that Center yes exactly try to
get smoked you just want to see here I
get in the car when like people have
their seats all like that I don't like
and I wanna do i generate an 18 my
friend Renee she would use to hate it
when I would get into his car and I was
sitting like a normal person he goes man
why you [ __ ] had your [ __ ] seat
all lit up like a little [ __ ] I'm like
I don't know what that has to do with my
sexuality but okay that's what all the
homies always told me I look like a geek
yeah so I he would push you a [ __ ] my
[ __ ] back yes all the way gotta make me
lean even if there's no one to see you
can't have it up like that it has to be
healthy it gotta be at an angle what if
what if this one behind you then there's
just like a nobody behind me about me
and my [ __ ] ego [ __ ] yeah if
you go into those cars the seat is like
touching the back seat yeah I don't know
why maybe they're just trying to take a
nap while they drive the city there
needs to be an artist right now that
affects us like Tupac did yeah Justin
Bieber what the [ __ ] area you're not the
same what changes are dope but they are
shadows yeah
they're not even talking about Michael
Jackson level [ __ ] yeah yeah you know
Casey and I were talking about it last
night were like men if two phones ever
died here would probably be like Michael
Jackson level event like bigger than
what he ended up to be right yep for
sure
that's crazy my jay-z is like there for
a lot of people but even been to me
emotional yeah he doesn't get that
emotional string - yeah even biggie was
kind of cool
video was good not it not a level to
pause but I felt like he was more
effective than jay-z oh yeah yeah but
you been on the same caliber oh I'm bad
days I'm gonna kill me now so I can play
that's not pleased
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out of here